on October on October 29th the Broncos
upset the Chiefs Russell Wilson has
three touchdowns two days later on
Halloween on October 31st the Broncos
come to Russell Wilson in his camp and
say we need you to acquest to your
injury guaranteed a $37 million spot and
say you don't need that anymore Russell
Wilson then says no basically the team
threatens that if he continues to say no
they're going to not only bench him
they're going to make him inactive for
the remainder of the Season keep in mind
the Broncos were in a playoff hunt
Russell Wilson was playing some of the
best football of his career if you look
at the numbers 26 touchdowns only eight
picks nearly 67% completion percentage
over 3,000 yards and the Broncos were
back on track and it's interesting I
started to talk to some of the Denver
Broncos players throughout this winning
streak and they were saying we finally
got our in we've got our Juju on both
sides of the ball and we can count on
Russ because we know we have a
quarterback that can win us games when
it matters most and if you go back to
that critical win over the Buffalo Bills
Russell has that kind of signature
pouette touchdown pass in the end zone
they beat Buffalo they beat Cleveland
one of the NFL's best defenses and it
really looked like Denver was on the
verge of something special now they lose
to New England Russell's able to tie it
up 23 y ultimately lose and the playoff
hopes are essentially squashed then we
learned today that Shawn Peyton goes
Russell Wilson directly and says you are
now being benched for the remainder of
the Season we're going to go with Jared
St sources with uh direct access to the
situation tell me that the Broncos just
two days after the Broncos beat the
Chiefs front office came to Russell
Wilson Shan pton they came to Russell
Wilson and they said we need you to
remove your guaranteed injury and if you
don't you will be inactive that is a
significant threat made to Russell
Wilson in the mid of a playoff race and
one quite frankly that I've never heard
of
before I see the comments I smell a
lawsuit you think the backup would be
answer is this legal well that's why to
answer your question is this legal
that's why the NFL and the NFL PA got
directly involved after this
happened and you know if if if Russell
Wilson were to be cut he gets there's an
$85 million dead cap hit on the Broncos
you can kind of put the pieces together
and say okay I can see why Denver is
going to do that based on these actions
today but it's really one of the
stranger stories one of the more
unprecedented things I've heard in my
years covering the NFL as an Insider to
go to a player especially one of this
caliber who's playing really well some
of the best football he's played in some
years and tell him we need you to remove
your $37 million injury guarantee and if
you don't here's the threat you will be
inactive for for the rest of the season
that is a massive threat to make to
Russell Wilson and obviously he said no
as he probably as he definitely should
have as I would have as any player would
have who's already negotiated that in
his contract and then you have the
scenario that's moved forward where it's
really seems in
untenable